bonjour jérôme marty merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a dit ah vous faites partie des
signataires de l'appel qu'ovide 19
france
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire entendre
précisément à travers cette initiative
vous savez que nous avions fait une
précédente tribune mois de juillet pour
le port du masque en lieu clos parce que
toutes les les références et une
internationale nous montre que les
points de départ de clusters ou de
foyers épidémiques sont en les murs et
pas à l'extérieur on a bien vu que le
gouvernement avait tenu compte mais pas
assez puisque notamment dans les
entreprises ou dans les lieux scolaires
il n'est pas annoncé de port de masques
pour le la présence d'un aérosol de
particulier à la suspension et on ne
nous parle maintenant plus que de
distanciation socialo distanciation
physique alors même que aussi qu en lieu
clos il ya cette présence de ce fameux
nuage virale et que donc que l'on soit
un mètre de m ou 10 mètres de son
vis-à-vis si l'on est dans une pièce où
il ya de la particule virale en
suspension le risque est qu on la
respire donc on dit il ya danger de
propagation ou d'accélération la
propagation avait la reprise du travail
il faut donc que dans chaque entreprise
avec la médecine du travail et les corps
sociaux constituent et les syndicats on
discute de la mise en place de ce port
du masque un lieu clos justement ces
discussions ont lieu en ce moment même
au ministère du travail avec les
partenaires sociaux et les syndicats
vous attendez concrètement que le port
du masque à l'intérieur soit soit rendue
obligatoire c'est ce que c'est ce que
vous voulez partout en entreprise mais
aussi ailleurs en latin oui qu'il est le
véritable prise de conscience sur ce
mode de contamination qui est le
principal toutes les modes de toutes les
études maintenant le montrent ces
l'aérosol itation c'est la particulière
à la suspension qui est la principale
voie de contamination de cette maladie
il faut donc en tenir compte
il faut donc changer l'heure des pièces
en ouvrant largement les fenêtres et en
iran et puis en portant le masque ce
qu'on ne veut pas par dessus tout c'est
à la fois revivre la situation que nous
avons vécue en mars et en avril et puis
sur le plan économique que l'on ne met
pas en péril des entreprises parce qu'il
ya des cas déclarés dans leur en leur
sein et à ce moment là qu'on les ferme
pendant quelques jours donc il faut
éviter d'avoir à la fois un péril
économique un péril sanitaire de plus ou
moins 2
vilain rendent le port du masque
obligatoire dans certaines parties de
leur commune les magasins maintenant le
masque est obligatoire assez
régulièrement ce n'est pas toujours le
cas dans les entreprises vous le disiez
à l'instant pourtant est-ce qu'on est
sur la bonne voie pour l'instant au lait
je pense sur une prise de conscience
quand même on voit bien que les chiffres
augmentent on voit bien que le taux
d'incidents se rapproche de plus en plus
du seuil d'alerté dans beaucoup de
régions on rappelle que les seuils
d'alerté de 50 pour cent mille et au nez
par exemple la région parisienne à 46
pour cent mille
donc on voit que l'on va rentrer dans
une période qui est une période
dangereuse et qui doit faire qu
accélérer avec la reprise du travail que
l'on peut compter à partir du 15 août et
qui va augmenter jusqu'à jusqu'à début
septembre
donc il faut impérativement qu'on mette
en place des mesures qui tiennent compte
des éléments scientifiques le port du
masque à l'extérieur oui quand on est en
concentration de populations partout là
c'est plus un geste politique j'ai
sanitaire mais le port du masque en lieu
clos nous paraît extrêmement important
le puy du fou qui va ouvrir ses portes
aujourd'hui à plus de 9000 personnes
c'est un danger pour vous un danger on
sait que si vous voulez quand honnêtes
les uns sur les autres là vous avez un
risque de transmission
quand on va se coucher alors que
certains que la contamination manuportée
on le sait maintenant est moins
importante que par exemple pour la
gastro entérite
il ya aussi des risques que vous
projetez en poussant des particules sur
votre vis-à-vis si vous ne portez pas le
masque donc il faut porter le masque
alors vous dire que la dérogation de
nashville et fondée en tant que médecin
ça me paraît assez difficile il ya un
seuil qui a été fixé à 5000 dhs encore
une fois ces seuils de ses mille et
différent quand vous avez cinq mille
personnes les unes sur les autres ou
5000 personnes dans un grand espace on
entend encore des personnes plutôt
plutôt contre en ce port du masque
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous auriez
envie de leur dire que c'est c'est à
nous d'expliquer et de re expliqué en
corse et à nous d'expliquer pourquoi il
y a une présence virale qui maintenait
dans toutes les régions de france que
notre crainte est que ce chiffre
augmente partout et en même temps alors
que dans la première
vad en quelque sorte ce que nous avions
connu c'est une augmentation très
importante dans l'est de l'ile-de-france
maintenant on voit bien que le navire
allait sur tout le territoire dont ont
compris et donc si on rentre dans une
période véritablement d'hospitalisation
et de réanimation
c'est tout les hôpitaux qui vont être
touchées toutes les cliniques et vont
être couché et l'on craint que ce soit
difficile au moment où la grippe à
revenir au moment où on va avoir les
épidémies de gastro entérite et c'est
cet automne il faut tout faire pour
empêcher cette cette augmentation là est
vraiment le principal moyen c'est le
port du masque on préfère un port du
masque en confirmant donc porter le
match voilà ça sera un message de la fin
merci beaucoup jérôme marc médecin
généraliste et président de l'union
française pour médecine les draps merci
merci
[Musique]